Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 2, vitesse spatio-temporelle.
On sait désormais décrire la position de
la pomme en termes de ses deux coordonnées
sur la grille.
Comme on l’a vu, on interprète la ligne
d’univers comme un déplacement à mesure
que s’écoule le temps propre.
Les coordonnées de la pomme, qui décrivent
sa position, vont évoluer, elles dépendent
du temps propre, et il est donc intéressant
de définir une notion de vitesse.
La vitesse de la pomme, dans l’espace-temps,
est une flèche, un vecteur tangent à la
trajectoire, dont l’orientation épouse
son mouvement.
La longueur de cette flèche traduit la vitesse
du mouvement.
Cette longueur est la même partout car les
graduations de temps propre sont régulièrement
espacées sur la trajectoire, ce qui signifie
qu’en l’espace d’un même temps propre,
la pomme parcourt toujours la même distance.
De façon plus générale, tous les objets
de l’univers se déplacent avec exactement
la même vitesse.
C’est une constante universelle, qu’on
appelle vitesse de la lumière, et que l’on
désignera par la lettre c.
On peut alors écrire une toute première
équation fondamentale, qui dit que la longueur
du vecteur vitesse, sa norme, est toujours
égale à la vitesse de la lumière.
Lorsqu’on utilise des unités cohérentes,
par exemple si on mesure le temps en secondes,
et les distances en secondes-lumière, la
vitesse de la lumière vaut précisément
1.
Cela signifie simplement que le temps devient
une mesure de distance.
Le temps propre d’un objet, est simplement
la distance qu’il parcourt dans l’espace-temps.
En l’espace d’une seconde de temps propre,
la pomme se déplace d’une seconde-lumière
dans l’espace-temps.
On désire maintenant décomposer le vecteur
vitesse, en fonction des coordonnées.
Pour ce faire, à partir de la pomme, on trace
deux flèches sur la grille qui représentent
les directions et amplitudes de chacune des
deux coordonnées.
Ces flèches sont ce qu’on appelle des vecteurs
de base.
On les notera e0 et e1, en fonction de la
coordonnée qu’ils décrivent.
A partir de ces deux vecteurs de base, on
peut décomposer le vecteur vitesse, comme
une somme.
Ici par exemple, deux flèches bleues, et
une flèche rouge.
Les nombres 2 et 1 sont ce qu’on appelle
les composantes du vecteur vitesse.
La valeur d’une composante mesure la vitesse
à laquelle augmente la coordonnée associée.
En quelque sorte, on zoome sur la pomme, et
on mesure le rythme auquel elle se déplace
le long de chacune des deux coordonnées,
au cours du temps propre.
De façon plus générale, on peut écrire
que le vecteur vitesse est la somme de ses
composantes, multipliées par les vecteurs
de base associés.
Dans les expressions mathématiques, en relativité
générale, il arrive souvent qu’on effectue
la somme d’un même terme, appliqué à
chaque coordonnée une par une.
Par exemple dans l’équation précédente,
on a écrit la vitesse comme la somme de chaque
composante multiplié par le vecteur de base
respectif.
Pour pouvoir compactifier cette écriture,
on peut résumer la somme toute entière en
n’écrivant qu’un seul de ces termes,
et en remplaçant le chiffre qui désigne
la coordonnée en question par une lettre
grecque, par exemple alpha, qui va parcourir
chaque coordonnée une par une.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la notation d’Einstein.
Lorsqu’une lettre grecque est répétée
deux fois, une fois en haut, et une fois en
bas, il s’agit en réalité d’une somme,
dans laquelle cette lettre grecque désigne
chaque coordonnée une par une.
Pour finir, illustrons ce concept de vitesse
spatio-temporelle à l’aide d’un exemple
concret.
On imagine un satellite en orbite circulaire
autour de la Terre.
Lorsqu’on l’observe depuis une position
lointaine, le mouvement du satellite peut
être décrit à l’aide de deux coordonnées.
Le temps que l’on mesure sur notre horloge,
t, et un angle, phi, qui décrit la position
du satellite autour de la planète.
En analysant sa ligne d’univers, on peut
tracer le vecteur vitesse du satellite en
chaque point.
Ce vecteur vitesse peut alors être décomposé
sur nos deux coordonnées.
La première composante nous donne sa vitesse
temporelle, c’est le rythme auquel s’écoule
notre temps par rapport à son temps propre.
Si cette valeur vaut 2, cela signifie par
exemple qu’après chaque seconde de temps
propre qui s’écoule pour le satellite,
notre temps se sera écoulé de deux secondes.
La deuxième composante représente sa vitesse
angulaire, c’est le rythme auquel augmente
l’angle que forme le satellite autour de
la Terre.
Si cette composante vaut 10 degrés par seconde,
cela signifie par exemple qu’après chaque
seconde de temps propre, le satellite aura
tourné de 10 degrés autour de la Terre.
La première des équations qu’on a obtenues
nous permet d’affirmer que la longueur du
vecteur vitesse est toujours la même.
Il s’agit de la vitesse de la lumière.
A première vue, on pourrait penser qu’il
suffit d’utiliser le théorème de Pythagore
pour calculer la norme de la vitesse à partir
de ses composantes.
Mais il est très important de comprendre
que les coordonnées ne représentent pas
des distances concrètes, leurs valeurs, et
le rythme auquel elles augmentent, sont des
nombres arbitraires, qui n’ont pas réellement
de signification physique.
Par exemple, même si l’angle que forment
ces deux satellites augmente au même rythme,
il est facile d’observer que cette même
rythme ne correspond pas à la même vitesse.
Le satellite le plus loin se déplace le plus
vite.
Une même composante de vitesse ne correspond
pas en réalité à la même vitesse physique.
Dans les prochaines vidéos, nous verrons
comment résoudre ce problème, comment obtenir
une vraie mesure de la vitesse à partir de
ses composantes, en construisant une nouvelle
version du théorème de Pythagore, plus perfectionnée
et plus générale, qui fonctionne dans l’espace-temps,
et pour n’importe quelle grille.